よろしくお願いします
アラハント和解 イエサンサンニッチャヨナッティパリニャータボージャナ
スンニャトーアニミットーチャヴィモッコーイェ
間違ってると思います
ヤッサゴーチャラ  間違ってるような気がしますけど
他の版には違う言葉が書いてある
ヤッサゴーチャラという風に覚えた覚えがありますけどね
イエサンゴーチャラになってくるとちょっと節が壊れますね
スンニャトーアニミットーチャヴィモッコーヤッサゴーチャラ
アーカーセーワサクンターナンガティンテーサンドゥランノヤー
だから注釈書でヤッサゴーチャラですね
注釈書 これどんなテキスト？ それは PTS 版のダマパダ
これ？ はい 長老 下になんか下にちょっとヤッサって書いてありますよね
ここ あ これはイエッサだ
すいません  ヤッサゴーチャラ
まぁ注釈書ではね まぁそうなってますからね
はい この経で皆様に関係ないことでこちらで悩んでしまうとね
関係ないことでまた悩みが生まれますからね
えっと あの これもあの阿羅漢に達した人の心はどんなものかという説明なんです
これあのね あの仏教が語るね
最高な立場というかね
人間たるものは目指すべきゴールっていうのはね
阿羅漢になることですからね
悟りを開くことですからね
一体悟ったらどうなるのかというね
悟りって何なのかとかね
やっぱりそれ本当にいいものかとかね
まずいものじゃないかとかね
色々まあ一般的にはね
知りたくなるのもなりますしね
そういうことで まあ一応真理に達した人の心境がどのようなものかと
まぁ結構経典ではまぁいろんなところで語られてはいます
いくら語ってもこんなでいい
こんなんなのでいいのかという疑問は一般人には生まれますね
だからあの 私は今日ちょっと体が調子が悪くちゃってね
あの倒れちゃったんです
朝 そこでも頭が動かなくなったりして
今も今日もロレスは回らない可能性ありますけど
え？ストレス ストレスは回らないかもしれませんだけど
一応私はいくらかよくまあ調子はまあ戻りつつなんですけど
眼鏡が一緒に病気になっちゃった
これは治らない 眼鏡には関係ないんだけどね
下見るとこっちなんで
はい それであの 阿羅漢に達すること
悟りに達する人のはこんなものだ
こんなものだとお釈迦様おっしゃってますけど
まあそれでも一般人にはね
まあそれでもわからないと思います
これ理解できるギリギリのところで
お釈迦様がおっしゃっているところで
で 阿羅漢に達するということは
人間には絶対ない経験なんですね
たまにでも間違ってでも
もうある経験じゃないんですね
だからまるっきりない経験について説明してもしてもね
それはわからないでしょうに
ですから 我々知っている世界から説明するしか方法ないんですね
それで知っている世界とは違いますよという話ですよ
論理は それで知っている世界はいいもんやという風に微塵でもあると
阿羅漢の境地っていうのは
なんだ寂しいんじゃないの？ということになっちゃうんですね
だから たとえお釈迦様でもね
悟ったらどうなるのか
悟った人の心はどうなんだい？とかね
聞かれても たとえお釈迦様にさえ
これは説明はできないんですよ
だから  アワーチャンというね
こんなのはもう言葉がないんだからということでね
もう放っておけと それは目指して頑張ることでしょうと
いうことで厳しく戒める時もあります
はい この偈も一応悟ったならばどんなものかという
と説明するところなんですね
イエーサンサンニチェヨーナッティ
サンニチェっていうのは蓄えですね
でしたっけ 蓄え 財をっていうのは余計
この紙を裏返すれば日本訳ありますからね
で それはできない方々は自分を裏返すしかない
[笑い]で 財を蓄えることなくと書いてますけど
しっかり理解する場合は
財をということはもう余計なんです
それは解けて 解いてください
もう除いてください 別に取り消さなくてもいいんだけど
これ文章は成り立たないんだからね
財をと書いているだけで
意味は蓄えがない そこで何をといったら何でもいいんです
自分思い浮かぶものはね
これ何でもいいんです
財という一つだけに限って欲しくないんです
ですから 彼らには蓄えがないなんです
[紙の音]次はわかりやすいね
イェーパリンニャータ・ボージャナ
これは後でややこしい説明は
その気になるならば説明しますけど
まずは一般的な誰でも使っている
ボージャナっていうのは食事ですね
それはパリンニャータ
夜よく食べるって何やとよく知ってるんですね
知り尽くしている これをわかりやすく
日本訳の場合は食物でしたっけ？食べ物について
その本性を知りという風に
本性 本性 本性を知り 次
シュンニャトウ シュンニャトウっていうのは
難しいね 空ということですね
仏教でよく 仏教と言ったって般若心経でよく使っている
あの言葉 単語なんですね
般若心経の人は空は何やとわかってなかったんですけど
仏教はそれを知ってますからね
シュンニャトウ いわゆる空性なんです
空であること 空であること
空性 番目アニミット アニミッタっていうのは
訳すとペティキュラースになっちゃいますけど
特色 特徴 こちらは無相と書いてますね
相という漢字がありまして
これは漢字で意味が通っているかどうか分かりませんだけど
物事には特性がありますよ
どんなものにも自分の特性があるんです
例えば リンゴ2つ リンゴでしょうに
で 2つ見たら この2つはそれぞれ違うとすぐわかるでしょ
もう何のことなく誰でもわかります
だから人にリンゴ2つ持ってあんたどちら取る？と言ったら選べるでしょう
私はこれでいいやと だから大体くじを引きような感じで
何も見えない箱の中に手を入れてなんとか取るような感じで我々生きてるわけじゃないんです
リンゴ1個取っても あ
これでいいということに選ぶんですよ
だからその時は全然無意識的に特徴を
特相を調べているんです
何か書こうとすると ボールペン3つありまして
じゃあ目を閉じてどっちでもいいやじゃないでしょ
なんとか一つ取っちゃうんですね
なんであなたこれ選んだんで聞いたってもよくわからないんだけど
本人は しかし 無意識でちゃんと判断しているんです
これではなく これではなく
これ使いますよと ということで
一切の物事に特相があるんです
他のものと違いますね
特相がなくなると結構困るんです
で 水入れがありますとしましょう
で そこであの自分が飲むカップに
ガラスにそこから水を入れると
そうすると これはもう私の飲む水だと特相が現れますね
ガラスに入れた時点で
では その水をまた元に戻したらどうですかね
そうがある あなたの飲みたかった水はどこ？ともうわからなくなるでしょう
そこでなんで自分が飲む飲もうと思ってガラスに入れた水をまた元に戻ったところでわけもわからなくなっちゃうんですね
というのは そこで特徴がないんですね
そこで水という特徴があるんだけど
自分が飲みたかった水という特徴が消えてしまっているんです
だから困ったもんなんですね
もし自分の子供の特徴がわからなくなっちゃうとどうなるんですかね
あのゾウアザラシっていうんですか
あのあの Zという動物たちがね
もう 300頭とかね  400頭とか海岸でだらーっと並んでいて
あのゾウさんみたいなでっかい体でしょ
あれで子供たちは子供たちの群れでいるんだからね
どう見ても同じなんですね
全く同じですよ しかし
そのお母さん お母さんは自分の子供を知っているんです
特徴は知っているんです
ですから 間違って誰かの子どもにおっぱいあげて
はい さようならと出ていくわけことをしませんね
ゾウアザラシは必ずしも自分の子供におっぱいをあげているんです
だから その場合も たくさんの似ているものの中から特徴あるものを選んでいるんです
そういうことで この特徴という言葉をよく理解してほしいんです
仏教を理解したければ
だからずっと言いますから
仏教は宗教じゃないんだからね
拝んだり信仰したりっていうことではないんだからね
しっかりそういうことを学んでほしいんです
例えば皆さん 今いるところで柱 2つありますね
こちら皆様の左側 で やっぱり柱と柱の特徴はわからないまま
あちこち上天井見たって天井に柱がありません
で そちら柱 2つあります
皆様にはそこを見ただけで特徴があるはずなんです
しかし 私は知っています
この特徴あると言ったって
この前か後かだけの特徴なんです
これ切って別にして どちらでしょうかと言っちゃうとわからないんです
それでこれ外せませんだけど
外せるものだったら外す人が 1と2と書くでしょ
まあね 今大掃除の時間だから
あれ襖というんですか
開けたり閉めたりする
あれは外しちゃうでしょ
紙を糊を 入れ替えるためとかね
これで好き勝手に付けちゃったらもうあまりはめませんだからね
一応一二三四とか書くでしょうね
なんで我々はものに一二三四と書くのかというと
特徴がわからなくなるんだからなんです
そこで特徴をつけちゃうんです
表裏とかね 上下とかね
時々文字で書く羽目にもなります
時々は文字でなくてもわかる
では 花の表と裏なんかは別に書かなくてもね
すぐわかります だからいろんな機械にね
いろんなことで 例えばファクスの場合は表面は裏にしてくださいとかね
わざと書いてないと もう我々はもう白い紙を隠すする羽目になっちゃうんですね
だから見ただけで あ あの文字書いてるものはここちら側やと見ただけでわかるならば
あの説明は要らなくなるんです
だからね 時々昔のスイッチだったらね
ガチャンと入れるものでしたけどね
機械的に 今はタッチしただけでも十分というのスイッチもあるし
しかし触っただけなんですよ
でっかい機械がそれで動いたりもするし
時々それで機械が動くとわかるならば
スイッチオンかオフかは言う必要はないんです
しかし 機械は動いてるんだけど
それは特徴がなく わからないんですね
その場合はスイッチ入れているか消しているかとわからないでしょうね
これ困るんですね その場合は小さな光がスイッチの中に付いてるんです
スイッチ入れると光がついて
スイッチ消してると光も消えてるとかね
あるいはスイッチは入れたり切れたりしない場合は
スイッチオンの場合は緑で
オフの場合は あの 何でしたっけ？オレンジ色になったりする時もあります
そうやっていろんなものを見ると
みんな特徴を使用していることはわかるはずなんです
先生 特徴っていうのは特徴です
特徴  とく まあ特徴なんですけど
ここでは特徴なんですね
仏教専門の世界では この相という漢字使ってますからね
特徴とどんな感じ  今日は長い長音でもいいんですけど
行人殿に山書いてを書いて
山書いて  そうですか ああああ
まあ特徴でもよろしいんですね
それだったらね まあ仏教は漢訳する場合は
この相というね 木偏でね
目を書く感じになっちゃいますね
特色という感じもよろしいんですけど
で 色というのは色ですからね
だから色と言ったって
本当に色というわけでもなくてね
自分のスペシャルでしょ
パティキュラーでしょ
だから抽象的にはそんな風になりますね
特色というのは青か赤かということではないんだからね
いわゆる何でしたっけね
この毒 特毒 毒というかね
あるものが他のものからどのように違いますかということなんですね
日本語の勉強はやめます
もう授業はとにかくどんなものにも一貫あるものであっても
特徴があるんです そこで大きな石がある
それはもうすぐわかります
あ これこの石やと これサンニャーというのはそれなんですよ
それで石を見たら頭の中でサンニャーが生まれるんですね
だからその場合も相という漢字書くんです
だから意志が自分の特相を心に記録するんです
それが勉強することなんです
結構勉強しているんだということをたくさん層を記録しているということなんです
この特相がわからなかったら
もう知識は生まれません
だからガラスの水を元の入れ物に入れちゃうと
もう特相が消えてしまうんですね
消えるわけじゃなくて
水という特相になっちゃうんです
自分が飲みたかった水ということがもうなくなっちゃったんです
ですから この知識にはかなりのすごい大事なというかね
必然的な条件なんです
特相は すっごく頭がいい人っていうのは
特相を発見しやすい人なんです
頭悪いって人はなんかもう発見しないんですね
物事の特相を はい アニミッタ
ニミッタっていうのはこの層ということで
アニミッタっていうのはないっていう無相ですね
だからもう意味わかるでしょう
単純に無相だけいきなり勉強したってもね
それは理解できません
ですから 特相っていうことは先に勉強してください
特徴でもよろしい 特色でもいいんです
すべての物事には特色があると
それで悟りに達した人にとってはこれ一切なしと
もうちょこっとインスピレーションになったら
もうわかるはずなんです
悟りは何なのかと ガラスの水が
じゃあ元の水を入れてる瓶に入りました
それそんなようやつ悟りはと思ったら
これ勘違い なぜならば今その水が自分の特相を持って
ってますからね 水入れがありますね
そこに水いっぱいあって
あなたのガラスですかと
それは はい わかります
はい ドロドロと注いであげる
じゃあこれを私が飲む水ですよと
ちょっと待ってください
また取って元に戻すと
それでガラスにあった水の特殊特徴がもう消えちゃったでしょ
サッサと取るっていうのはそんなもんでしょうかねと思っちゃうでしょうね
それが違います なぜならば
この私が飲み飲もうとした水という特徴が消えちゃったんですけど
水入れの水という特徴が持っちゃったんです
特徴を持ってしまう 別な特徴に変わっちゃったんです
で そういう風に次から次へと特徴が変わっちゃうんです
その同じ水入れの水をあの雑巾にちょろちょろと入れたりして
雑巾をちょっと濡らしてもらう
そうすると 雑巾の中に付いている水は自分の特徴を持っているんです
それでちょっとテーブルを拭いてから絞るとまた水でしょ
それはまた別な特徴を持っているんです
そういうふうに水であっても
次から次へとそれぞれ特色
特徴を変えては変えてはいく
これ科学的にそんなこと言ったってどこでも水でしょ？H2O でしょうのというのは
もうそれはまた頭でっかちの考えで
事実はそうじゃないんです
認識の問題なんです ものはあろうかなかろうが関係ないでしょうに
生きているものにとっては
我々は何考えるかっていうことが我々の命でしょうに
だから物理学 科学っていうのは
人の命には関係ない科学なんですね
こちらは人が生きるということの科学ですから
絵に描いた虎であろうか
本物の虎であろうか 関係なく怖いと思ったら怖いんでなんですよ
だからその恐怖感を感じた人は確実に恐怖感を感じた
それで科学的に説明したって
これは実際の猫かの虎
あなたを見たわけじゃなくて
なんとか何とか顔料で壁に描いた何か顔料見たんですからとかね
だから何と俺が怖くなったとだけの話でしょうに
だからあの科学的な説明はほとんど余計になっちゃうんです
問題は認識にあるんです
虎が粘土で作ったか もう顔料で描いたものか
本物かどうか そんなのは関係ないんです
認識に問題 認識が生きることだから
そこが問題なんですね
ですから あのガラスに入れた水はまた元に戻ったんだからといってね
科学的には何の変化も起きてないんです
ただ 入れ物変わっただけのことでしょうに
しかし 仏教にとってはかなりの変化が起きているんです
認識が変わるんです 相当変わってしまうんです
それで人生は左右されますよ
だから水は全然変わってないんだよと言ったってもね
それを仏教研究では管轄外
そういうことで特徴 特色
特相という この一言葉が大変な意味があるものなんですね
だからまた前 あの途中でやめた例に戻ります
石があるというね 石が見た瞬間で認識の中にサンニャーが生まれる
相が生まれる それは特相
その石を見ると その相
本棚を見ると別な相が入りますからね
そこでその石をもうなんとか金槌で打って割る
2つにする  2つにした瞬間で
それぞれが自分の特相また持つようになる
それで新しい特相  2つが2つ心に入り込む
またこれ砕いていくと
その度に特徴が変わっていく
そこをスーッと石が砕いてきて
たくさんもう砂利になったりとかね
最後に粉にまでなったりすると
そのずーっとその変化の特相記録することができる人が結構頭がいいんです
私たちはすごい面白くないということでまとめちゃって
まあまあ石が壊れてるんだ
終わったということにしますよ
で 途中で興味がなくなっちゃって
もう終わっちゃうんですね
いわゆる特徴を取れなくなるんですね
それがcapacityなんですね
人の あの どれぐらい人には勉強できるのかということは大体計算できないでしょう
だから そうやってちょっとした実験するとシンプルなね
その人の興味はどの程度で消えてしまうのかということでcapacityがわかるんです
普通は人間にはどれぐらいのことを勉強できるのかといったって
これよくわからないんですね
頑張れば何でもできるんだぞという理論
理論も入れちゃうし しかし
実際は一人一人が自分のcapacityは持ってます capacity
は増やす 増やすことはできますよ
当然 いくらでも伸ばせますけどね
しかしcapacityはあります
それはちょっとした実験でわかります
何かにすぎて どこまで自分が興味を持っていくのかと
だから特徴を取れると興味が
一応興味があると特徴を取れる
特徴を取れると興味が湧くというのは必ずじゃないんです
特徴を取ると興味が生まれるんです
一応 特徴を取ると興味が生まれるならば capacity
はいくらでも伸ばせます
面白い 面白い 面白いと出ていっちゃう
進んでしまいます やればやるほど面白いんだと
しかし 初めから人間には面白い
知りたいという興味があって
知っていくと あ 疲れちゃったということで終わっちゃうんですね
普通は だからそういうふうに人間は 2つに分けることもできます
勉強すればするほど面白くて
面白くて どこまででもやるというね
そういうオタクのグループと
それから まあちょこちょこっとやってみて
まあ面白くない 別なものにしましょうという簡単に冷めるタイプと
だから簡単に興味が失って別なことに走る人は当然頭が悪いんですね
だから日本人の特色である熱しやすく冷めやすいというのは断言
人的に無知な民族って意味なんです
みんな自慢げに言ってますけど
役に立たんって意味なんです
だからしつこい人っていうのは日本語ではあれもう貶す言葉でしょ
本当は頭がいいって意味なんですけど
簡単には諦めないんです
そういうことでね 仏教からね
いろいろ面白いいろいろそういう豆知識もいっぱい出ますよ
何の役にも立ちませんだけど
それでもね はい しかし
これお釈迦様の言葉になってくると
そんな冗談では済みませんよ
で 特色がなしと無常と言ったら何ですかね
分かったらおかしいんです
だって分かるのは特色が分かるんだからね
涅槃が分かった分かったと何言うんですかと
分かるという言葉は成り立たないんです
無常であることなんです
空であることなんですね
すべての現象は  3番目の言葉はヴィモッカウ
解脱 自由 で これもなんとなく分かったような気がするでしょう
でも分からないんだよ
本当の意味は 我々は この
これは一番分かりやすい言葉でもありますよ
空であること 空性というのもう人間には理解できない言葉なんですね
で 解脱はなんとなく分かりやすいと思いますね
これ自由って意味だからね
これも相対的に分かれます
イメージ的に分かります
あるいはいくらかの経験的には
なんとなく なんとなく分かることなんですね
で 日本ではやりませんだけど
アメリカでもやってるかどうか分かりませんだけど
自分の国はね もうピンからキリまで政治ばっかしですからね
まぁ 米 1キロ買う場合でも
どんな党を応援しているかっていうことはかなり影響与えます
ですから まぁいろいろ犯罪を起こして裁判を受けて
あの刑務所にもう入れてる連中っていうのはたくさんいる
そこで政治家がね 好き勝手に
じゃあ独立記念日には
じゃあ 40人を解放してあげますとかね
大統領のお誕生日を考えて50人とかね
そういうことは結構やってます
だから人を殺して刑務所に行ったっても
大統領の機嫌ぐらい取っておけば
俺をお願いしていれば
じゃあ今度の誕生日なんとかしてね
あるいは あの なんとか記念日にという
あの 5月お釈迦様のウェーサーカ祭に対しても
何人かがそうやって自由になったりはします
いいことか悪いことか
やっぱり私はちょっと判断は分かりませんだけど
うん そこで例えば 20年
20年の刑とかになっている人が
20年っていうのは普通は人の一生ぐらいですからね
もう若い時やられちゃえば大丈夫なんですけどね
大体犯罪を起こす時ってもう大人ですからね
5年目になった だから本人が一生刑務所で死ぬつもりでいますよ
それで 連絡は来る 今度大統領が自分の誕生日のためにという
なんとかその記念日 あるいは独立記念日の日で
人の人々が自由にすることにしましたとかね
免罪にするというんですかね
あれは パロ ん？恩赦 あ
恩赦ですね 恩赦にすることになりましたと
で そのリストに自分の名前も入っていると
どんな気分かと 大体それ一日前に報告するんだからね
刑務所では あるいはもう 1 年間お互い喧嘩して
俺の名前入れてほしい
今度の独立記念日に俺の名前を入れてほしいとか
そういうことは刑務所の中では禁止でしょう
できないんですよ だから人に恩赦を決めるということで
いろいろ調べて人のリストは作るでしょうね
作っても 大統領はそれをちゃんとサインしない限りはね
で サインして そこは法律的に行くべきところにその文書は行かなくちゃいけない
そこで刑務所の監督をやっている人が前の日
リストが行くんですね
1 日前に  1 日前にその人々に名前を呼び読んでもらって
何何番号 何何番号 君らは明日からもう恩赦を受けますよと
しかし 今日 1 日はもう囚人ですけど
だからその 1 日は囚人でいてもどんな気分ですかね
だからこの刑務所に入れられる経験がないと
この安らぎを感じませんよ
だからなんとかやって刑務所に逮捕されてもらってください
だから過去世を思い出す必要はだからあるんです
むちゃくちゃいろんな
もうものすごい苦しみを経てきたんだからね
過去世思い出すどころか
もう 1週間前のことも忘れちゃうし
教えてもちょっと困ったもんですけど
はい これで自由というのをたとえ話ですけど
あの 恩赦 あ 明日から自由やと
だから そうやってかなり
あの 幸福な経験なんですよ
だからもう恩赦っていうのはものすごい安らぎを感じるんですよ
我々社会の中でも何か失敗しちゃって
もう弁償する羽目になったりして
あるいは叱られる 怒鳴られる羽目になったりするところで
向こうはいい あるいはもう忘れ
忘れますと なかったことにしますと
あのひと言ば聞くと ものすごく体全体が涼しくなっていくんです
ものすごい幸福の波が現れていくんです
そういうことで この束縛からの自由という一言葉だけは
なんとなく人間にはもう感じられることはできると思います
核を知っている人ならば
それだけで十分ですよ
もうもう解脱しようではないかと思っちゃうんです
核を知らないんだから
いくら言ってもそんなつまらないことは俺にはいらんやと思っちゃうんですね
ただ瞑想して ちょっと体重だけ痩せてもらえば
もう体重だけ減量してもらえば十分やと
はい ではそれで涅槃の境地わかるかというとわからないんです
それでもなぜかというと
もう年に決めた人は五年目で突然明日から君お膳を受けるんだよと言われると
無茶幸福感 自由 楽しみを感じますが
これ一時間ぐらい経ってからどうなる？その人は
これから帰ってから私はどうすればいいかとかね
あれもやりたい これもやりたい
こうした方がいい こうした方がいいとかね
あれやこれやと あまりにも限りのないいろんなことが頭に入っちゃうでしょ？出た途端
まずこれやっちゃいますよとかね
あれでまた刑務所なんです
自由が失っちゃうんですね
また刑務所っていうことは
刑務所からは実質的に出ますけど
本人がまた束縛されてますね
だからこれって本当に自由っていうことじゃないんですね
例えば結婚して頑張るもうまくいかなくて
喧嘩ばっかりで 互い気持ち悪くて
もうやっぱりやっと覚悟して
じゃあ別れましょうと
まあその時は自由は感じますけど
次 一日足らないうちに
じゃあ私はこれからどうすれば？ということが出てくるんですね
だからもうすぐ二日の中であの喜びの波動が消えていくんです
であっても この一時的な解放感でも
本当にすごい幸福の波動があるんです
それで悟りっていうのは
これ絶対的な自由なんですね
だから決して悟ってからどうすんの？っていうのは成り立たないんです
あんた何聞くの？どうすんの？って
別に全部自由になっちゃったんだから
あします こうしますとはないんだよと
そこで我々は束縛の目ながら
やることなかったら超つまらないんでしょ？最悪でしょうと思っちゃうんです
だから結局は涅槃後を説明するヴィモッカ解脱という言葉さえも
結局はわからないままで終わっちゃうんです
だから いくらか比較的にわかりやすい言葉なんですけど
これ単語ミスですよ シュンニャとアニミット
ヴィモッカ この場合はまた別なところで別の単語使ったり場合ありますね
シュンニャタイムとアッパネーとイモッカ
なんだかんだありますね
もう一つありますね もう一つあります
アッパネーとイモッカ
シュンニャとイモッカ
ヴィモッカはまだ滅に分けてますけど
頭がもう年取っちゃって
もう昔覚えたものはもう頭にはさっさと浮かんでこないんです
[笑い]あれみたい 目
そういう目というのはね
難しい そこで空であること
無常であること それから自由であることが彼のゴーチャラというのは管轄
悟った人はその範囲 それゴーチャラっていうのはこの管轄に入りましたというね
いわゆるもうわかるようになりましたと
次はまあそれでも分かりませんだからお釈迦様はたとえ話を持ってくるんです
カーシーはサクンターナン
空に空にいる鳥たち サクンタっていうのは鳥
サクンターナン・ガティ
ガティっていうのはもう動いた跡ですね
形跡ですね 人間であろうが
動物であろうが 蛇であろうが
砂の上で歩いたらね 歩いた形跡は残るでしょう
空には鳥 鳥たちが空を動いているんです
しかし 形跡は一切なし
空を飛ぶ鳥も鳩も 庭で庭の上であちこち行ったり来たりするとよく分かりますね
足も汚れているし だからもう結構跡がつきます
その鳥が飛んだら こちらから枝まで飛んだら
その道だけは 跡はないんですね
そんなようなものであると
ガティ・テーサン・ドゥランナヤン
テーサンというのは彼らのガティ
どんなものかと どこに生まれるのかと
心はどんなものかとかね
死後どうなるのかとかね
これはドゥランナヤン
あなた方の管轄外であるんだと
知ることは不可能であると
アンナヤっていうのは
この推測する 論理的に考える
ロジックではディダクションと言うんですね
知るところかディダクションするところまでも不可能であると
いわゆる推測することさえも
可能です だから精密な意味はドゥラッナヤっていうのはそういう意味なんです
undeductible
deductというのと難しい英語ですけど
普通の英語でassumeという言葉使いますね
それ難しいね assume
というのは会話の英語では我々は I thinkと言うでしょ think
というのは考えるということですけど
時々assume 私はではないかなと思いますよというね
ことで随分シンプルな単語になってますけど
やっぱり専門的なことを喋る場合は
シンプル単語を使うと意味が間違いますからね deduction
なんですよ deductive
と言ったっても これはlogicの言葉でなければいけません
あの数学にもありますけど
それではダメです まあそんなことはどうでも専門用語どうでもいいんですけど
あの推測不可能であると
なんで推測すら不可能であるというっていうのは
推測するのはほんと知ることできないんですね
例えば 太陽がどれぐらい熱があるのかとかね
そろそろ予言通りに聖書のあのすごいでっかいフレアが出て
あの地球はもうかなり破壊する羽目になりますと
2012年です あの科学者とあの頭イカれているノストラダムスとか
また聖書とか そこを合わせてもうまた予言は出ています
あの人は 2000年で終わると言っていたんですけど
12年  12年延期になりました
延期になりました それまた延期にするでしょうね
だからこの連中どこまでアホかということになる
科学者たちが そこでNHKの番組か何かの番組で
いや  NHK じゃなくて民放でしたけどね
で また番組はいつ放送するかわかりません
私はこのプレビューで
いろいろ日本の専門家がね
こういう太陽やらあれやこれやもういろいろデータ比較したり
データ調べたり これでこれでこれで
もう大変やとか だからこの言いたいのは
太陽がどんなものかとかね
フレアっていうのはどれぐらい
こんなのはわからない
我々には経験することはできません
だからいくらかの情報であのdeductionするんですね
この間 何か月にね あの何か放り込んじゃって
する その場でこれ爆発して壊れちゃっちゃったんですけど
その機械が しかし その瞬間でちょこちょこっと何かデータというか
信号が出てくるんですね
この信号からもう計算して計算して
もうもういろんなもうものを作って
ものを作ると言わない
あの 何て言いますか 何て言いますか
もう単語ほとんど忘れていっちゃいるんですね
あの あの空想的な何か作ることを何て言いますか
この科学世界でコンピューターを駆使して
いろいろイメージを作ったり
こうなるだろうとか作ったりするでしょ
推測  え？ 推測 シミュレーション
シミュレーション で そこでいろいろシミュレーションしたり
いろんなことをしたり
月には水がありますと
あるようですよと言って十分ですけど
やっぱり今日で気が済まないんですね
彼はこういう状態でありますと
また量もこれぐらいだというんだからね
私はちょっと待てと言いたいんですけど
だからそちらはシミュレーションというかね
やっぱりこの 何か機械を放り込んだところの地形とかなんとかとか似ている面積を考えて
この面積計算するのも推測なんですけど
こちらこの 1点で水の水分見つかったならば全部あるだろうと
だから一箇所でこれぐらいだったらこれぐらいね
これぐらいでしょうとか
まあ随分計算するんですね
だからどこまで推測が行くのかとね
もうキリがなく持っていっちゃうんですね
はい それであのdeductionの例なんですよ
だから行って水のサンプル持ってくるのはちょっと金がかかるんですね
どこか国がお金あげるならば
アメリカが作りますけど
誰もあげないんだから
やっぱり もうこういう無人の機械を飛ばそうということで
次のステップの研究はアメリカではないんです
ただ その時その時 もうわいわいとキャーキャーと騒ぎ騒ぎ立てて終わると
だから一番無意味なことっていうのは
人間が月に行ったことなんです
あれで何買えたかというと
まるっきり 0 なんです
だからソ連はもっと技術は発達していたのに
月に着陸計画はなかったんです
あいつらより先に行くぞと
バカじゃないかと思いますけどね
ただそれだけのことで
そこで自分やっていることは無意味だとわかって
それからそちらもそのプログラムは中止で
宇宙ステーション作るということに
で 考えるところ もっと前もソ連の方が宇宙ステーションの計画作ってあったんです
あれ あれ壊れて落ちたんだからね
一応時間切れで そこで宇宙ステーションを作ったところで
いろんな国々のお金を集めて
なんかアメリカのアメリカこそすごいということ立場なんか消えていくんですね
宇宙ステーションの場合は
他の国々は研究プログラムを持ってるんですね
アメリカは何も持ってない
俺こそすごいぞっていうことは消えちゃうんですね
だから手を引くと で 手を引いちゃって
日本人がロシアのあれで飛んだんだからね
はい そこは余計な話ってどうなるんですかね
で 一応 知らない研究データを取る方法がない場合は
経験することはできない場合は
ちょこちょことデータを取って推測する
解脱に達した人については
もう無想だからね これはもうありえない
なんです はい それでわからないんだったらいくら空を見てもね
鳥たちは飛んでますけど
全くも形跡ないでしょうと
だから解脱に達した人は肉体ある限りは見えるかもしれませんだけどね
どんなことを考えているのかって
やっぱり心があるんだから
考えることはこんなもんだなとはちょこちょこ言えますね
それは密ですね それによって空であること
無常であること それから自由であることは
心の管轄外に入ってますね
それだけやと だから何か
考えるのかと言ったっても
これ相当我々の管轄には入らないことなんですね
いわゆる考えてないんですよ
だから私はずっと瞑想指導するとき言ってる
この思考の停止なんです
特相あると 特色あると認識が生まれるんです
我々は目を開けて見えるものの特徴ばっかりとろとろしているんです
特徴を取れない場合は見えないんです
皆様には間に空気見えないでしょ
なんで空気見えないのか
特徴は取れないんです
それで煙でも出さないとね
なんとかあのドライアイスでもね
使って何かで落ちちゃうと
もうそこら辺の空気だけ見えるんですね
それ特相つけちゃったんですね
で それで耳で音の特徴をとっているし
だからとにかく特相取りっぱなしなんですね
それで認識が起こりっぱなしで
それで思考しっぱなしで
これは終われないんですね
恐ろしい勢いで起きてるんです
そこは思考は停止ということはね
これ大変なことなんです
ですから この時々ね 私はこの思考を停止することというかね
考えることをやめることが仏道やと
そんなことお釈迦様も仏教じゃない
あれやこれや思う人々もいるようなんですけどね
まあそれはそれでちょっと勉強不足というかね
まあ調べてないだけの話で
私は結構なことを調べてから決するだけ言っちゃいますから
みんな誤解してしまう可能性もあります
そこはちょっとしょうがないということでね
でもあの証拠はこれなんですね
私はなんで即座に考えることをやめちゃえばいいんじゃない？と言うんですね
あなた考えることやめたら
やめることできたら その時点で悟りやと
随分簡単なようでしょ
だから なんでこのお坊さん
すごい仏教はなんかからかってるんではないかと思うかもしれない
からかってはいませんよ
純粋に本物を言ってるだけ
わかりやすく 現実的で
実践的に 専門的なブッダの言葉になってくると
こういう大変なことになります
大変というか これは完璧な教えになりますからね
思考を止めちゃえば悟りやというのは
そんなそれほど完璧な言葉じゃないんです
思考を止めちゃえば悟りやと言っても
だからその人はなぜ思考起こるのかと
この思考を起こさせる原因を取り除かない限りはね
思考は止まらないし それで思考を引き起こす原因は現象の特相なんです
しかし 私たちと悟った人の違うところは
例えば石一個ありますね
だからこちら石一個あるでしょうにと
触ってみなさい 石でしょう
触られると これちょっと持ってみなさい
重いでしょう 持てないぐらい
そうですね 重くてとかね
そういうふうに私は理解するでしょ
どこかデッカい石があって
見たら あ これは石 あれ
これ作ったもの？あ もう作ったものじゃない
テレビ局でもね 石がありますとでっかいものはね
でも本当に石のように見えますけど
全部作ったもので 足で蹴っ飛ばせます
で これ見たらもう触ったら硬くて
ああやっぱり石 それでもちょっとおかしいと思って重い
持ってみようと思ったら
もう持てない ああ もう決まった
もう石だと そうやって決定するでしょ
どうやって決定したんですかね
あらゆる特徴なんです
特色 特色なんです 見てみる
触って もう叩いてみる
それで観測の特色 で 持ってみようかなと思う
それも観測の特色 あ もう石に決まっていると
そこで石というものがあるというふうに結論するんです
実体論にも入ってるんです
だから石というものがあるということは
こちらでいる私が認識したんだからと
これで自分も実体論に
そういうふうにも瞬時に無意識的になっているんです
この無明が基本的なOSに入ってないと
こういうことできないんです
だから無明であるからこそ
科学者はすごい科学を研究してノーベル賞を取っちゃいますね
だから相当無明がないとできないんです
だからすごい優れた科学者でもね
個人的にはだらしなくて
いろいろもうもうあれこれだって悪くいろんなこと言ってもね
だから当たり前なんです
無明で頑張ってます 無明だからこそ特徴が本物やと思って
徹底的にさらに特徴を調べていくんです
しかし シンプルな例で特徴って何とわかるはずなんです
ガラスに水を入れる それだけでその水の特徴が変わるんですよ
それでまた元に戻った時点でまた変わるんだから
特徴そのものがいい加減でしょ
何のことないでしょ だから石の例出したらそういうわけで石を割ったら別々特徴生まれて
また割ったら別々なもの生まれてきて
それで砂利で大きさになったらまた別な特徴を持っていて
それぞれによって我々の認識が激しく変化して人格まで変わるんだけど
人格を変えさせたものはどうったことない
もうただの１か２か変えただけの話なんですね
ふすまに そういうわけで
特徴そのものがいい加減で何の意味もないんだと分かった人にとっては
無想っていうことは経験することができます
だからギャーギャーとこの仏教心理学というのはね
これ悟りっていうのは宗教的な神秘体験じゃなくて
この知恵の開発なんです
はい それで芸の説明は終わりました
これ悟る気分になりました
ほら なってないでしょう
そこがずっと言ってるポイントなんで
本当は私がやったレベルの説明っていうのはもう専門家にも不可能なんです
経典通の人にもここまでできないんです
そこまでやってるのに
全然解脱してやろうかなという気分になってないんですね
まあだからそれ別にこれは批判的な言葉ではなくて
それが状況なんです 人間がえらい身を張ってね
自我を張って 何やとあなた方の悟りやとかね
言うとお釈迦様は答えなくちゃいけないんですよ
それで答えているんです
答えてももうベロを出すか
もう首をこうやって横に曲げるかっていうことは
もうお釈迦様も期待している結果なんです
あまりにも自我出して質問すると
最もこれは自我出されたケースじゃなくて
これは本当に知りたくて
勉強したくて 謙虚な人にした説法なんです
だから なんとなく分かったような
という気分になるんです
もし皆さん 私の話に乗ってしまっていたならば
この空想の話に 特色の話は真面目に
皆様の世界から真面目に乗っていたならば
もうなんとなく分かったような気にはなります
あるいは自由という言葉の話もね
これで空であることというのは
私は今日説明は控えます
これも同じく難しいんですよ
特相の方が今日は一応説明してしまったんですけどね
一応同義語であることは同義語なんですね
はい それより皆様は気持ち悪くなるのは蓄えは一切なしということなんです
かわいそうですね 嫌でしょうね
そんな解脱は 解脱に達してたらもう蓄えはまるっきりないというね
蓄えって何ですかね 研究してないでしょ
とにかくバカみたいに蓄えるだけでね
アリ塚とありますね アリ塚は誰が作るんですか
白アリなんです 普通のアリではないんです
アリ塚に住んでるのはヘビですけど
ヘビやらトカゲとかね
作るのは白アリです それで空気をはいるために
ものの見事に穴を作るんです
穴も設計上 自動的に現れてくるんです
白アリたちの設計上 アリ塚の太さ
硬さっていうのは この環境に合わせて作りますけど
どう作ってもずっと空気が通らないと
で だから設計上 自動的にかなり大きい穴が現れちゃうんです
だからそこは空気が通ると
この土の中から空気を通して
ずっと白アリたちに生きてられるように環境が現れます
ものすごい面積した地面を掘って作りますよ
そこでアリ塚の話はなんで持ってきたかというと
あの連中はとにかく土を練っては作る
練っては作る 練っては作る
どこまで作るべきかさっぱりわかってないんです
それでどんどん作ったものは全部そのまま放棄して
別なところでまた新しく作るんです
そこ硬くなって またそこを放棄して
また別なところを作る
どこまで作るかと切りがない
自分のグループの生活を安定するための作戦をやめればいいでしょうに
そこまで考えてないんです
もうとにかく それぞれの白アリが自分の仕事をしているだけ
白アリは早く死にますけど
生まれた白アリがもう自分の一生死ぬまで仕事はする
仕事をするということはアリ塚を作ることなんです
すごい忙しい 次に生まれる連中もまた仕事して死ぬ
次に生まれるもまた仕事して死ぬ
だからアリ塚作っては放棄すると
だから新しい あ 俺たちは仕事しなくちゃと別なところで始めなくちゃいけないでしょ
だからこのアリ塚が出てくる場所っていうのは
かなりの面積 一ヘクタとかね
軽く地面でもう全部取ってらしてるんですよ
これであの 我々にはこの壁とかを作るために必要な土が新たに変化しますけど
農業にはとても悪いんです
あれは死んだ土なんです
粘土というか粘り気もあります
だから水とごちゃごちゃすれば
もう結構粘り気のある粘土なんです
しかし死んでいるんです
だから土は微生物も何も生活できないように死んでしまうということは恐ろしいことなんです
でもまあ無常だから アリ塚もね
放棄されて 何年か経つと雨が降ったり
いろんなことにしてね
また細菌が入り始めますから
植物は出てきたりする場合もありますけど
で 我々の人生もね アリ
シロアリとは何の変わりもないんですよ
もう作るは作るは だからシロアリは破壊するでしょ？逆に
食べるのは木だからね
食べて食べて食べてアリ塚を作る
その上に人間も破壊しつつ破壊しつつ蓄える
蓄える蓄えて 我々の人生そのものが蓄えることで
シロアリとはまるっきり同じなんです
蓄えたものはそのまま放棄して死ぬんです
だから結局は迷惑な代物
代物ばっかり残っちゃうんです
で 何蓄えても全部もう残して放棄して死ぬしかないんです
しかし 我々は蓄えがないっていう言葉ほど嫌なことはこんなもうもう新しいね
正月になるし そんな時言って言うべき言葉じゃないでしょうと
あれは私のしょうがない
今日は九十二番目ですからね
[笑い]では蓄えるってどんな精神ですかね？どんな気持ちですかね？どんな心理状態ですかね
なんで蓄えるんですかね
将来に不安がある  将来というのは知り得ることもできないのに
不安がもう止まらないでしょ
将来は知り得るものでもないんです
将来知ってる人っていうのは
生命っていうのはいません
ですから 将来に不満があるっていうことも
それほど適切な言葉ではないんです
想定外の出来事に対応する
将来何が起きるかわからないから
そのために何か備えておこうと蓄えて
うん 将来は知り得ないから蓄えるといえば
いくらかまあ点数は 取れますけど
欲で蓄える  欲で蓄えますからね
まあ蓄えることによく考えなきゃできないっていうかね
うーん まだなんか違うなと思いますね
なんで蓄えるのかと  今の暮らしを続けたい
そうも思ってないでしょ
もっと良くなりたいとはない
もっと良くなりたいと思ってない？ 昔はそうでした
昔は確かに相当そうでした
もっと良くなりたいと思いました
今ちょっと現状維持でもいいかな
でも蓄えは必要です  でしょ
現状維持するために  うん
将来のシミュレーションを実現しやすくするために蓄える
将来の例えば自分がこういう風な人生を歩んでいく
だからそれは蓄える機能の説明であって
なぜ蓄えるのかというね
何でだということにはね
答えが出てこないね  無知で蓄える
無知も現金は当然ですけどもね
俺が無知だからいっぱい蓄えてやるぞっていうこともちょっと
ちょっと成り立たなくなっちゃうんですね
なぜならば 蓄える人が自分が理性だと思ってるでしょ
だからなんかまだまだしっくりしないんですね
苦を避けるために 苦をドゥッカを避けるため
腹が減るとかですね  させるために？ 苦を避けるために
避けるために うん ね うん
だからまあそれもありますけど
で 今の苦をね もう避けちゃえば
それで物事済んでるでしょう
はい それで一応答えは出ているんです
そういうややこしいことなんです
なんで蓄えるのかというと
やってはいるんだけど
あんた何やってるのか
そんなこと聞かれたって困りますよという答えなんです
だから見てみれば誰でも蓄えますよ
誰でも必死でたこえますが
えーと なんででしょうかと聞いたら
そんなこと聞かれても困りますよという答えなんですね
ということははっきりしっかりしてないんですね
だからこれ治療ほとんどややこしいんですよ
これ原因だって言ったら
はい これしなさいって
これがかなり解脱の世界ではね
かなりややこしいところなんですね
怒りの場合 分かりやすいでしょ
で 原因があってね 例えば隣り一階でいる人々はすごくうるさいくて
こちらで勉強できなくなると怒ってくるんですね
怒ったと 怒りが出たと
原因がありますね 一階にいる人々はすごくうるさい
はっきりした原因で怒ったら
あの怒りを収めるのはそんなに難しくないんです
例えば一階の人々はすぐ静かになってくる
その上謝ったりもする
すいませんでしたと 気づかなかったと
それでこちらそっと怒りが消えちゃって
まあいいということになっちゃうんです
あるいは逆に私はそんなことでもうあんたなんで怒るのかと
いい加減無視しなさいよと
あんた性格出来が悪いんだと言われたら気持ち悪いかも
悪くなるかもしれませんだけど
じゃあそうしましょうということになったら
また私はでは怒ってますけど
うるさいことに対しての怒りは消えるんですね
だから原因がある場合は
解決策ははっきりするんです
しやすいんです それで我々はもうなんとなく怒っていて
もうすごくカッとなったりしたり
原因がわからない場合は
もうどうしようもないと
対処法も出てこなくなっちゃうんですね
それで怒りの例でよくわかりやすい
どんな例でも分かりやすいので
例えばある女性見たら
あの子は可愛いんだからあの子を私のものにしたいなと思ったら
はっきりしたターゲット定めているでしょ
それだったらどんな手段でどんな工夫して
どんな騙しをやって自分のものにするのかっていうことはもう見えてくるんですね
誰でもいいんだから 女性と一緒になりたいと思っちゃうと
その人にとってはもう取る手段がなくなっちゃうんですね
それで頭がおかしくなっちゃって
かなりもう破壊してしまうんですね
だからどんなケースであっても
原因はっきりする場合はもうなんとかなります
それでなぜ蓄えるのかっていう質問に
皆様には全然納得いける
私が納得いく返事はできませんでしたね
それが答えなんです どんな説明したっても
もうちょっと違うんじゃないかなって
はい それでブッダの答えがあります
不満を感じているんだからなんです
今の瞬間で不満を感じているんですね
別に将来のこと そんな大げさなことじゃなくて
今の瞬間を置かれまして
不満と不安を両方感じるんです
満たしてないんです 不足という感じがあるんです
足らないと それがまた
理由がありますけどね
だから答え簡単 今の瞬間に置かれては不満を感じないことなんです
それってすごい心の境地なんです
なぜかというと この存在は
現象は不安を感じるようになっているんです
理由は すべての物事は無常で一時的だから
完全なものは何一つもないんです
無常というのは不完全という意味ですからね
完全だったら変わりませんしね
だから物事でき事は無常っていうことは不完全だから
不完全だったら満足いくわけないでしょうに
人が料理作ったんですけど
もう不完全で だったらそれ食べたっても満足はしないでしょうに
そういうことだから 我々は自ずから瞬間瞬間不満を感じる
そこで満足したくなるんですね
で蓄えちゃいます で ご飯食べるのはお腹が空いてるからだといいつつも嘘ですよ
いつも冷蔵庫に置いておくんだから
で 米はね  1合ぐらいは今あまり 1合も食べませんだけど
まあ 1合食べれば十分だけど
1合買っちゃえばいいでしょうに
5キロか 10キロのパック買っちゃうでしょ
だからそういうことで
私はなかなかもう体に悪いものばっかり食べる羽目になったのは
自分で米なんかご飯作っても別に時間もかかるも何でもないんですからね
大体皆様よりは私にはご飯をすごく美味しく炊ける噂は持ってますけどね
で 毎日ご飯作ってますけどね
私が米研いでスイッチ入れたらね
かなわないと思います
そこまで技術もありますけど
作らないんです なぜかというと
10キロか 5キロのパックを買わなくちゃいけないんですね
あれが嫌なんです もう 3ヶ月間ぐらい前かな
玄米も佐藤さんと一緒に走って味探して買いましたけどね
やっと昨日で終わったんです
はい とにかくそこは私は変人だからそれは置いておいて
まあ普通は店でもパックで売ってます
前昔私はもうよく調べたこともありますよ
このちょこちょこで料理を作りたくて
玉ねぎとか必要な玉ねぎ 1個だけ欲しいんですね
トマトも 1個 もう嫌 売ってないんですね
そういうことで この食べたいんだから買ってますよというならば
その分だけね 買っちゃえばいいんだけど
やっぱり 料理作る場合も
やっぱりこれはもう弁当に弁当の分まで作ったりはしますね
そういうことで 我々にとってはどんな瞬間でも
不満がありますね これだけでは困りますよと
本当は将来のことはさっぱりわからないんです
あの現在に対する不満が
我々は将来に対する不安だと勘違いしているだけ
実質的に将来は知り得ないんです
我々将来将来というのは
現在に対する不満なだけなんですね
それはどこまで膨張させているのかということなんです
だから あまりにも将来を考える人がすごく病気でしょ
だから現在の不満をちょっと管理できないところまで膨張しているんです
だから 将来を気にしない人も
気にする人であっても
誰でも将来は知りません
というか 知りえませんですね
はい それで最後のポイントに戻ります
えっと 蓄えが全くない人になりというと
あ 嫌だこれはと思っちゃいますね
仏教はやってますから
いっぱい蓄えが自動的にバンバン貯まった方がいいでしょうね
現世利益ですから 宗教は
思ったもんでしょ だから現世利益をどんどん宣伝しているということは
いかに人はね 人の不安をね
あおいたたいてあおいたたいているということなんですね
いわゆる苦しみをあおいたたいているんですね
宗教の世界は 人々を地獄に行く道をどんどんどんどん作って
それそこ それこそ天国に行く道であると
今日で終わりましたけど
昨日まで日本はキリスト教でしたからね
あの ものの見事に今日のテレビ番組見るとまるっきり関係なく
もう日本の伝統的な話とかね
もう始めてるんです 昨日まで 1ヶ月間これ何やともうみんなもう本当にもうローマ教皇もびっくりするほど敬虔のキリスト教たちなんですね
だからあの 人々があのスピーカーでいろいろ文句言ってるでしょう
あれ 言ってること自体
地獄行きの言葉なんですね
神が審判するんだ 苦悩はみんな地獄に陥れるんだとかね
こんな極限の差別思考で生きること自体
心の汚れでしょうに 慈しみのひとかけらもないでしょう 「
神愛しなさい」と言うんだから
知ったことはないとどう返するんですかね
で どんな状況でも やっぱり人にはものの見事に地獄の道を教えているんです
しかし それが天国への道だとね
はい まあとにかくこの御利益を
なんとか御利益 なんとか御利益いう場合は
我々の今現在持っている不安を掻き立てるだけ
不満を掻き立てるだけ
だからすごい難しいんです
仏教は もう人々に理解してもらうということはね
はい ポイントに戻ります
それでお釈迦様が苦を発見したことは
いまだかつてなかったすごい真理だと
この2番目 実体を発見できたことは
いまだかつてない大変な発見であると
それで究極的な安らぎに達するんだと分かれば
だからなぜ蓄えるのかということで
答えは苦聖諦なんですよ
苦聖諦は事実だからなんです
蓄えずにいられないんです
一切は苦だから 不安だから
不満だから 将来のことじゃないんです
そんなところまでじゃないんです
その余裕はないんです
今現在苦なんです 不満なんです
不安なんです 現実 真理
実態 事実 だから勢いで蓄えているんです
この蓄える衝動がお釈迦様
渇愛と言うんですね その方が分かりやすいんです
渇愛が生まれたのも不満があるんだからなんです
そこを発見しないと この問題は解決しないんですね
ですから この三日蓄えがないということは
もう相当難しい単語なんです
これで何を意味するかというと
今の瞬間については不満感じないって意味なんです
だからその人は無常であると知っているんです
無常であると知っているんです
苦であると知っているんです
今の瞬間は だから蓄える気持ちが生まれないんです
それは悟った人の本当の心の中身
そういう心なんです はい
もう一つ言葉が残ってますね
パリンニャータ・ボージャナ
食 食べ物については 何て言ったっけ
本性を知り パリンニャータというのは知り尽くすという意味なんですね
食べ物については知り尽くすという
それは食べ物 ボージャナって食べ物って言ったってもね
こんなことで仏教ですかね
食べ物のこと知り尽くしてるんだぞっていうのはね
明らかに品のない話でしょ
だから分かりやすい この意味じゃないんです
食べ物のこと知り尽くしてて
この料理の研究家じゃないんだからね
食っていうのは何ですかね
食っていうのは 命っていうのは独立できんです
命は支えられて一時的に成り立つものであって
一番脆いものなんですよ
極限に脆いものなんです
支えられて支えられて成り立っているんです
だからこれが尊いやとね
神様が吹き込んでくれたとか何言うのかと
あまりにも妄想なんです
何の価値もないんです
生きることには 徹底した無価値で無意味なんです
その上 これ必死で支えなくちゃいけないんですよ
一瞬も休めないんです
支えなくちゃいけない
だって我々は栄養取るは
ご飯食べるは 歩いたり座ったり寝たり起きたり
いろんなことをやってきてるでしょうに
瞬間たりとも休めないんです
生きるという機能が 何も大したことやってないんですよ
ただ支えられるだけ 倒れないようにちょっと支える
また倒れる また支える
また支えると どこまででも支えてあげて
支えてあげてやっちゃうんですね
だから我々にはまるっきり余裕がない
暇がない生命なんです
暇があると思ったっても
本当は実質的には暇がないんです
休みっていうのはありえないんです
命には すぐ壊れるんです
呼吸みたいな派手な現象を見るとね
1 分間何回とか数えられますけどね
心臓という派手な現象を見ると
1 分間何回鼓動するかとかも言えますけどね
しかし実際は瞬間瞬間も酸素が交換しなくちゃいけないし
一緒に栄養は細胞に与えなくちゃいけないし
栄養与えなくても細胞ほんのちょっと生きているでしょうと思ったっても違います
あるいは蓄えた栄養を取っていて
また弾けますからね 終わったら
だから蓄える機能っていうのを我々は機械的にもやってます
細胞個もこの不満を感じているんです
だから 細胞の中にも自分の今だけの栄養でとって
はい 結構ってならないんです
余分に取って蓄えるんです
もし血液と一緒に栄養が来なかったら
中にある栄養を使うんです
で 電気機械が動くためには
電気はスーッと流れていなくちゃダメでしょ
電気が切断した瞬間で全部ストップするんです
命も同じです ずっと支えなくてはいけないんです
この支える機能がボージャナということなんです
だから食い物の話でもないんです
そこは知り尽くしてるんだということは
生きるとは何やということは知り尽くしてるんです
だから随分意味が違うでしょう
本を読んでみたらパリンニャータ・ボージャナ
食べ物については本性を知りと
呑気ですね  何？ 呑気な
本当の意味は生きるとは何や
命とは何やということは知り尽くしているということなんです
それが空を発見しているということであり
それで結果として渇愛が消えていって
情報認識 また私は別な定義で認識することできることというでしょ
その場合は特徴がないんだと
物事に何にも 知ってるんだから
そういうかなりの大変な境地なんですよ
覚るっていうのは というわけで諦めてください
そこであの注釈書では注をしていますけど
これダンマパダ長老でしたっけ？ダンマパダはね
えーと もう私が言うところは書いてないんです
あれはまた一般的に分かるところの注釈して終わっているんです
そういうわけで この一偈でもものすごく難しくて
もうクタクタくたびれるぐらいのすごい内容なんです
だからブッダはブッダっていうのはそういうわけなんです
四行で あの三 四行 あの
まあ二行 まあ四行分けちゃえば
まあ繋げりゃ二行ですけど
行目は誰でもわかりやすい喩え話でしょ
そのように人なら語れますかと
だからこの純粋にブッダの生の声っていうことは
あの お坊さんたちのものもあるし
そこちょこっとすき加えたものあります
そこだけ明確に抽出してみるポイントは
そのポイントなんですよ
もう恐ろしいくらい完璧なんです
すごい短く語る 完璧に語ると
何も欠けてないと これはもう不可能ですからね
言語を使用して そこで軽々呑気な解説も大丈夫という
だから役に立たないわけじゃないんです
例えばパリンニャータ・ボジャナっていうのは
まあ体に必要な量だけ食べているっていう程度の意味でも別に損はないんです
ただ体を維持する程度で食べましょうというぐらいの言葉でも
別に損はしませんだけど
それが全ての意味ってわけでもないんです
あの 俗的な まあ今言葉変わりますけど
まあ呑気的な解説ではちょこちょこっとこの引っかかっちゃうんですよ
例えば蓄えはなく まあ量知って適当に食べるんだと
量知って適当に食べるんで
いくら蓄えがあったってもいいでしょう
たくさんいろんなものは
ケーキとかね いっぱいクリスマスで買ったものは残っていく
あれで自分がパクパク食べないならば別に
だから本当は俗世間の考えで言えば
自分があるんだったら食っちゃう性格だったらね
まあ一人暮らしで もうコンビニからケーキ買いましたと
あれは個か個まとめて売ってるでしょ
困ったもんですよもう
コンビニでは個でしょうかね
あのスーパーでは一応個ですね
だから たまたまでも食べたくはなるんだけど
行って買わないで戻ってくるんですね
[笑い]残り二つどうするのかと
例えばある人がこれもったいない
まあしょうがない もうまあこの際まあいいやと言って食べるならば
この人蓄えない方がいいでしょう
危ないんだからね 食っちゃいますからね
で まあ食事に対して量を適度知って食べる人は別にでっかいケーキ買ってもちゃんと量分だけ切って食べて
はい さようならということになりますから
問題ないでしょう だからこの引っかきが覚えてください
もし食べ物は適度知って食べる人なら
それができる上手な人なら
別に家で食べ物蓄えがあったってもね
あんまり大きい問題じゃないでしょうに
だから即的な呑気的な解釈では悪くはないんだけど
微妙に論理が合わなくなるんです
この微妙なところは引っかかっちゃうんです
結構注釈書とかいろんなところでそういう微妙なところに引っかかって
そこは明確に解説しないんですね
はい 今日はそこ それ以上は今日は 2つやろうかなと思ったらこれ無理ですね
はいはい どうぞどうぞ
兄とあの無相ということについて教えていただきたいのですが
これはあの悟った人にはその
これは何だという認識が生まれないということなんでしょうか
それとも外から見て その
例えば空気のような人というか
外から見て相がないということなんでしょうか
この意味をちょっと理解ができないので質問しました
はい あの  あの認識はね
悟った人も生きてますから
あの普通なね 肉体を持って脳細胞を持っていますよ
ですから この 明確に区分けするんですね
俗と聖というね これすごい上手なんです
例えば悟るためには瞑想して知恵を開発するでしょう
ですから この相を発見することは誰よりも抜群にできるんです
もう知恵が無茶あるんです
だからこそ微妙なところまで行って
この無常を発見するんです
だから俗世間にいる我々もこの特色を知ることで知識が増えてきますね
そこで直足をする能力には派手な差がありまして
我々の世界では頭のいい人も悪い人も出来上がっちゃうんですね
この瞑想して頭いいところじゃなくてもう良いことはもう感性にまで持っていっちゃうんですね
ということは 特徴なら誰にも気づかない特徴まででも取れるんです
で 俗世間ではもう一番頂点に達しているんです
ある一部ではね 次に解脱の世界
そこから性 特徴はないんだぞと
で 発見することによって解脱の境地に達するんです
だから日常生活ではこのどちらでも使えるんです
あと 簡単な例を言いましょう
お化けなんかいるわけないんだと知っている
知ってるんだけど 子供にはお化けの話をする
いるわけないんだと知ってる人がお化けの話をすると
相当怖いんです 物の見事にそこはもう演じて喋るんです
なぜならば お化けという概念がなんで人間作っているのかと知ってるんだからね
その気持ち 感情をとことん引き立てるんです
実際 お化けがいるんじゃないと思ってる人にはそれできないんです
その人は本当のことだと思って勘違いしているんだから
データに基づいて喋るんです
だから お化けを信じる人のお化け物語は面白くないんです
あのね あの人 あの写真撮りました
そこで幽霊が映りました
ほらほら 見て見てとかね
それで苦労するんです
あるわけないんだと言ったら
もう物の見事に目の前にお化けがいるように錯覚を起こして語れます
そういうことで 特相が本来はないんだと知っている人にとっては
認識は誰よりも明確に認識することができるんです
悟った人の能力には敵わないので
誰にでも そういう 2つなんですね
もっとわかりにくいなあ
こんなこと人がお坊さんにね
悟った人に いかがですかね
今日の私は一生懸命食事を作りましたけど
なんか自信がないんだけど
いい？あなたの食べ物はとてもよくできてますよと
ちょうどいい具合に寝てますよと
揚げ具合はとても素晴らしいですよと
感触はよろしくて カリっとする音もして
もう味の組み立てはとても素晴らしいでしょうとすごく精錬に言うんです
びっくりするほど 感知ものすごい
繰り返して このすごいですね
この 私も気づかなかったという
それで作った人までね
で説明できます それ全然嘘じゃないんです
しかし 食べ物に微塵も執着はあったかと
まるっきりないんです
ただの品物だと感じるだけです
だからそうなんですよ
完璧なんですね 例えば偏見で見ると
もし人が悟ったら もうこの世の中ではもう誰とも話も通じなくなっちゃって
もうおかしくなっちゃうんですね
例えば先生 この花って結構大きくて綺麗ですね
あのね 綺麗って何ですかね
これあなたの錯覚でしょ
これで話にならんでしょ
ではなくて 本当に悟った人はもう確かにこれは綺麗ですと
で これはなぜかというと
こちらはこれであって
この色はこちらで濃くて
ここで見事に減っていって
これでこのもう形がこういう風にこういう風になっていて
光が当たると目にはこういう風になっていて
とても綺麗でびっくり
ただ単純に綺麗やと思った人にとってはね
について 美学として物の見事に教えてあげることまでできます
なぜかというと 本来は特徴ないんだけど
特徴ならブッダというならば全部知ってるんだよという立場なんです
これは修行中では難しい
修行中はだいたいお釈迦様とはね
一般人というのは随分能力の差がありますから
能力ない人も悟ってほしいんですよ
ですから この修行中は全部カットしてね
修行の世界に入り込んじゃって
オタクっぽくやってほしいんですね
それは能力はそれほどないんだからそう言ってるんですね
ややこしいことをやめなさいとね
変な社会に出てね どこかで
いろんな情報をカットして集中してみなさいとは言うんですけどね
それで誰でもかなりたくさん人々が悟るようになります
が それは断言的な決まりじゃないんです
それでなんとかわかりましたか？まだ不安がありますか
なんとなく そんなものかな
具体的なもう一つ例ありますよ
ある帝釈天がね この 1番目に 1番目と 2番目の天国の王様ですね
王様と言ったっても まあただ力強いだけなんですけどね
天国では王様が管理している政治がないんですからね
みんな自由ですから で
この人はお釈迦様との随分個人的な知り合いで
まあお世話したりもするんですけど
時々忙しくて会うことはしないんですね
この人はふざけていてね
自分の寿命が終わっちゃったんですね
長い間天国で寿命が終わったら
天界から死ななくちゃいけないんですね
そこであれ死んじゃったってことを感じたんですね
やっぱり普通の仏教の信者さんも同じですけど
もう死の死の特徴が出てくると
現代でもお坊さんに会いたくなっちゃうんですね
私はもう先がないんだとわかったら
お坊さんに会いたいということを言うんですね
会ってなんとか喋ってますね
帝釈天もね まあやっぱりお釈迦様はね
このお釈迦様に会わなくちゃという不安でしょう
心は 怖いしね 死にたくはないし
と言っても久しぶりに会ってないんですよ
だから会えないんです
お釈迦様に怒られる可能性あり
怒鳴られる可能性あるしね
お釈迦様ももうほとんど子供扱いしていたんだからね
そこをお互い二人ですごい仲良しでしたけどね
で だから仲良しだからこそ
かなり久しぶりで なんか都合が悪い時だけノコノコと出てくると
当然何か言われるんですね
だから本人が心配して
自分の側でお世話する側近のマートリという人がいるんですね
神ですけどね この人は帝釈天一緒にあちこち連れて行きますと運転手ですね
人間の言葉で言えば ですけど
音楽のプロなんです その仕事をしないで売れなかったでしょうね
おそらく 音楽家なんですけど
帝釈天の運転手やってるんです
で この人もお釈迦様の知り合いですね
そこでお釈迦様に会いに行きましょうと
いて二人で行って 帝釈天はもう帰らないんですね
かなり遠いところにいるといて
君先に行ってくださいと
先に行ってお釈迦様の様子を見て
実はお釈迦様の帝釈天もお釈迦様に会いたいと思ってますけどと言ったら
お釈迦様がね 許可するでしょ
その時私来ますよと 結構カラクリやってるんです
だから帝釈天がマートリさんに頼んだのは
自分がちょっと困ったことがあって
お釈迦様に会いたいんだと
だからちょっと機会を与えてくださいというのを頼んでくださいと言ったんです
よくわかりましたと言って
マートリさんがお釈迦様に会うんです
会ったらこの人 主人の言うのはどうでもいいんだという感じで
自分が音楽家でしょ あまり売れないってこと
まあちょっと冗談をすぎる感ですけどね
自分が失恋していたんですね
なんか叶わない恋をして
いわゆる神々とまるっきり正反対のまた存在がいたんですね
その人のリーダーの娘さんがいて
あまりにも美人で もう欲しくなったんです
しかし 一緒になるのは不可能で
性格はまるっきり違う世界だからね
だからもうかなりこれ失恋の痛みがあるんですね
その人はそれに歌作ったんです
あの人はいかに美しくて惑わせる美人であろうかというね
自分がまあせっかくね
まあ失恋は失恋で それは別にとどめなく自分が作った作品をね
これ発表したいんですね
でお釈迦様の前にどうですか？と言ったら
お釈迦様 私は歌を作ったんですけど
聞いていただけませんかと
言って もう神々ですからね
神々の楽器を弾いて奏でて
美しく歌うんですね だからどうせ人間の世界のある音楽とは違いますね
天の音楽だからね しかし
歌の内容はね ブッダの前で言うものじゃないんです
だって欲の歌でしょ おっぱいはどんなものやとかね
顔は髪の毛はどんなものやとかね
あなたと一緒になるなれとならねば今死んでもいいんだという感じのね
ブッダの仏教のブッダに言うものじゃないんで
とにかく それでもやっぱり恋は叶わないものやという風に
結構かっこよく作ったもんなんで
ずっと歌っていたんです
お釈迦様 何のことなくずっと歌を聴いていたんですね
聞いて歌終わったら結構評価してあげるんですよ
君の作品はとても良いと
演奏と曲の内容っていうのは結構合ってますよと
また曲の内容もね すごく欲が絡んでいて
で その上 世の中のね 叶うもんではないという心理にも心理も混じってあって
作品も結構よくできてますよと
だから作詞作曲全部一人でやるんだからね
あの人は だからこの二人は自分と自分の会話なんですね
もう帝釈天の頼みはもう後回しにして
それで自分の気分が晴れたでしょ
自分の発表もできましたし
お釈迦様がいい曲だと言ってくれたんだから
これまた楽しいし それで実は帝釈天も来ていますけどと
あ そう じゃあ呼んでくださいということで
それから帝釈天の話になりますね
あれ長部経典なる経典ですけどね
だからそこでわかるポイントはお釈迦様はブッダだからといって
なんかもう音楽なんか特殊あるわけないでしょうとかね
ただの音だろうとかね
それがないんです あんたブッダのお前に恋の歌を歌って
なんで侮辱でしょうか
無礼でしょうかとかね
それがなく よく聞いてあげるんでしょうし
それからすごく評論もしてあげるでしょうに
だから当たりさん知らないわけじゃないでしょ
ブッダはすごい聖なる方であると
やっぱり聖なる方 俗世間の価値は全部捨ててる方なんですけど
お釈迦様から判子押してもらった方が最高ということを知っています
もう文句ないんだそうと
どこでも堂々と発表できますよと
そういうことで それから帝釈天も来てね
お釈迦様とはこと帝釈天は結構難しい質問をいろいろ聞いて
それに答えをもらってね
大変法に対して喜びを感じて
お釈迦様にでは帰りますと植木する挨拶するんですね
自分が死にかけているんだということを言わなかったんです
説法を聞いたんです どうしても知りたかったいろいろポイントがあってね
それをずっと だから生まれ変わったらどこに生まれかわかりませんだからね
人間に生まれたらもうブッダに会えないでしょうに
だからそこあって大変喜びを感じて
お釈迦様にでは帰りますということで挨拶すると
お釈迦様はじゃあ仲良くできますようにと祝福したんです
それで瞬間で亡くなって
その瞬間でお釈迦様の前でまた帝釈天として生まれ変わったんです
つるつると まただから帝釈天がまだ若いんです
はい そのエピソードを言ったのは
この悟った人々は無想というね
我々には理解できない境地も知ってるんだけど
私たち凡人と喋る時はもういかに物の見事に喋ったりしますよ
それは全然問題ないんです
悟りに達した人は 社会ではそういう変な問題は全く作らないんです
気づきもしない 例えばお父さんが悟っていても
子供たちはまるっきり知らないし
自分の子供一人が瞑想して悟りに
したっても親は気づかないんです
あ いい子になったというか
賢くなった それで終わっちゃいます
はい そういうことで はい
うん 例えば音を聞いた時ですね
これは鳥の声だ  ちょっとマイク
音を聞いた時ですね これは鳥の声だとか
これは車の音だとか そういう風に普通は思っちゃうんですけども
それが単に音で止まっちゃったら
これは相は取ってないっていうことになりますでしょうか
だから私たち修行中だからそういう頑張っちゃいますよ
車の音やと幻想化しないで音で止めてやるぞと
我々は修行中だから そういう風な結構苦労しますね
悟りに達したら 達したら音とエネルギーで耳がぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃ動かしていることね
認識するんです とかね
ちょっと忘れましたね
質問が  要するにあの音っていうのは
その相がないと考えてよろしいんですか？音は相が
まあまあ 一応音は相なんですね
音も相ですから 空であるっていうこと
その話なんです 今日はそれ説明してなかったんだからね
音はいろんな原因によって生まれ生まれる現象ですから
で そこでもう空であることなんですね
空であることは何もないという意味ではなくて
因縁によって成り立っている現象であるということなんですね
だから 耳元の感覚も同じく原因によって生まれる現象であるというね
それで認識が 聴覚が生まれても
聴覚は原因によって生まれた現象であると
だから空 空 空というステップに行くんです
そこは四六時やっているかというとやる必要はないんです
もうその境地に達しているんだからね
しかし 例えば鳥の声は我々にも結構聞こえるでしょ
あれは鳥の声でいきなり決めるんだけどね
あれは人工的な作った声か区別大体できるんでしょ
耳できますよ  あともう一つ
全然関係ないんですけども
ダッティンディワディワンっていう言葉が夜と昼という言葉でディワっていうのがあると思うんですが
それでディワでディワーディヴァッサという言葉で
これがどういう意味なのかということを知りたいんですけども
ディワッタ？ ディワーディヴァッサ
ディワのアブラというと
おそらくデイティブだと思うんですけども
例えばウダーナとかですね
スッダ教なんかでディワーディヴァッサという言葉が出てくるんですけども
あ ディワーディヴァッサ
例えばスッダ青年がお釈迦様のところから戻ってきて
ジャナスの森にパーモンと会った時とかですね
そういう時にディワーディヴァッサという言葉が出てくるんですけども
これの意味はどういう意味かということをお尋ねしたいんですけども
ディワーディヴァッサというのをブレイクしてみて
エティモロジーを見るとどうなる？ 二つが一つになる
ディワーディヴァッサというのをどうブレイクする？エティモロジー
ディヴァセディヴァセ
エティモロジーでブレイクダウンする
ディワーヤディヴァッサね
あのまあおそらくディワーヤディヴァッサという風に分解するとね
これはサマーサですからね
名詞 2つ合わせてますから
合わせて用語を作ってるんですね
だから大体昼間って意味でしょ
あれは 意味としてはね
辞書にはですね 早朝にっていう風に書いてあるんですね
どうしてその昼間っていう言葉が早朝にっていう言葉が出てくるのかという
あ なるほど  例えばスッダ青年は
お釈迦様のところに説法を聞きに行って
で 説法終わって帰ってくるわけですから
早朝に出かけたとしても早朝に帰ってくるわけにいかないと思うんですね
だから昼間にでいいと思うんですが
どうして早朝にというような意味が
そういう意味が出てくるのかどうかということをお尋ねしたいんですけども
それがよくわからないんですね
やっぱりディワーディヴァッサということで昼の昼って意味になりますからね
だからそういう風に直訳はなんの意味も持たないしね
早朝でしたらパートーとかがよろしいですかね
だからはっきりパートーへわと書きますよ
ディバ アディ・ディヴァス
アディ ディバ アディ・ディヴァス
アディというダンマで
他にない言葉ね それがフレーズだからね
もうそのまま一般的に意味取るしかないと思います
分析しても フレーズというのはもう言葉の意味じゃないでしょ
結局は そこら辺 そこまで真剣に考えることしませんからね
パート  慣用句になってるんですね
そうそうそう  そういうふうに言われるのかどうかというのはちょっと
慣用句なんですね 一応
それもノリによって使う単語なんで
パートはノリが悪い場合は使わないんですね
もしパートだったら 経典っていうのは一応唱える言葉ですから
だって書く文化ではなかったでしょ
ですから 単語を選ぶ場合は結構ノリも考えるんです
普通喋る時でも 少し喋る人は結構ノリの良い言葉を合わせますからね
その時私が読んだとこを思い出すと
結構ノリが良かっただけなんですね
ノリが良くなるとすぐ覚えてしまうんですね
例えばアッペーヴァーナーマ
サッキャプッティア なんだろか
アッペーヴァーナーマっていうのはもともと慣用句で
早くって意味なんですね
別に 何の中身？分析すると全然出てこない
その意味はね アピ・エーヴァでしょうね
そういういくつか慣用句と言うんですか
ありますね それはそのまま覚えちゃって使うしかないんですね
例えば ではそろそろ帰りますという日本語の言葉あるでしょ
パーリ語だったら  いきますかね
そろそろ帰りましょう
そろそろ帰りますと それ一つの挨拶でしょ
日本語でいっぱいあります
では そろそろお失礼いたします
とかね  そういうことはいいんですけど
それがその早朝にという
だから早朝にではなくて
それはもう昼間という意味ですよね
早朝じゃないんです わざと早朝という時間設定だったらいくらでも単語あるんです
昼間中というね 午前中だったら午前中という言葉あるでしょうに
だから時間設定が大事な場合は
その大事な言葉を使いますよ
だからあまり意味がない単語を結構慣用句として使って
だからではそろそろ説明しますというのはこのハンダダーニなんですね
なんて言ったらまたありますね
で ハンダダーニマヤンガッチャーマというね
ハンダっていうのはなんかね
大変なことを言う場合使う単語で全然何の意味もない
それではなんていう意味なんですね
その場合は お釈迦様はこの最後の言葉使う場合
ハンダダーニという場合はすごい意味が深いんですね
その文字通りに見つかっていて
で お釈迦様にじゃあ帰ります
ハンダダーニマヤンマーセガッチャーマというパーリ経典ありますからね
大なる方では我々はもう行きますと
次にまた繋げてバフキッチャーマヤンバフカルニヤ
言わなくてもいいんですけど
我々にはいろんな仕事があるんだよと
やるべきことはいっぱい溜まってますからと
失礼であんなこと言ったら
お釈迦様の前で みんなその言葉なんですね
ハンダダーニマヤンガッチャーマバフキッチャーマヤンバフカルニヤ
我々にはもう仕事いっぱい溜まってますから
お釈迦様そろそろ帰りますよと
しかし それはもう勘よくで
で はい いいですよってお釈迦様サードゥーと言えばいいでしょ
言わないんです ヤッサダーニカーランマンヤタ
だから直訳しちゃうとおかしくなるんですね
ヤッサ 何かのことに今あなた方はカーラン時間だと時期やとマンヤタと思うであろう
それで終わっているんです
なんだこれと まあいいでしょうって意味なんです
まあとにかくあのもうディワーディワッサっていうのは
私はこれからちょっと考えてみます
読む場合はね なんでディワーディワッサ使うのかと
だからディワーヤディワッサという風になるかもしれませんだけどね
だからディワッサであってジェネティブでジェネティブかな
ディワーヤも同じケースでサマーサにするんですね
つなげて 時間表すだからどうしてもそのケースでなければいけませんし
まあまあただひろうって意味でしょうね
象徴 象徴のはパートエーワということを使うでしょ
パートだけではなくて
パートエーワ パートワになっちゃいますね
コンジャンクションすればパートワ
そんなところだなと思います
あまり納得いける 納得いける答えができなくてすみません
質問大丈夫でしょうか
全然大丈夫じゃないんだけど
はいどうぞ  蓄えについての質問です
インドの旅行に行って
インドを見て 日本に帰ってきて思ったことなんですが
インドはものがあまりなかったんですね
それに比べて日本は物に溢れているということがすごく差が目に浮かんというか
分かったんですけれども
この蓄えないということは
例えば蓄えると無駄になってゴミになって
それが資源を 環境を汚す環境破壊につながるということと
あと 蓄えるためにいろんなものを生命に害を与えるというか
いろんなものを大量に作って大量に捨てたりとか
また生命の牛や豚や殺したり
野菜をたくさん作りすぎてしまったりとか
そういう生命に害を与えるとか
そういう そういうことをしないための慎みの心という意味でも蓄えないということを行っているんでしょうか
全く違いますよ だから蓄えないということはそう簡単な話じゃないんですよ
それすごく説明したでしょうに
これ我々の認識範囲をも全く超えている心理の世界な
蓄えないということは
いわゆる今の瞬間に対しては不満を感じないということなんです
これは悟りの心なんです
我々は不満を感じているんです
我々いくら踏ん張っても蓄えちゃいますよ
これ蓄えについては質問を聞きながら
私はもう一つ説明するところはあったなと気づいたんだからね
で もう一度もうちょっと説明を新たに加えます
で それはしなかったんだから
その疑問が起きたんです
あの蓄えないというね
蓄えがない人生と言ったところで
皆様にこのみんな蓄えのない人生しなさいという提案ではございません
これは悟りに達した人の信仰
心境の説明なんです 我々にとっては修行中の我々にとっては雲の上の話なんです
蓄えがないという 財を蓄えないという意味じゃないんです
この日本語訳とは違います
蓄えがないという意味なんです
だから最初から私はこの財でしたっけ？え
財 それが余計やと言ったでしょうに
それでお釈迦様が一般的
一般の方々に喋るか説法する場合は蓄えなさいと言っているんです
何があるかわからないんだから
何か災害とかね 何かあったらその時使うために
いわゆる FOR THE RAINY DAYS というね
英語で言えばね いくらか蓄えなさいよと
シガラ経典ではっきりあるでしょう
だから日常生活では まあ言った通りね
明日どうなるかわからないし
世界はどう変わるかわからないし
病気になるかわからないし
突然ね その場合は決して借金するのは仏教は反対ですね
金借りるのは 金借りることを認めているのは投資目的だけになっているんです
投資以外金借りてはあかんだったら
当然現実的にはいくらか蓄えなくてはいけないでしょう
それで調子に乗ったらもう極限に行っちゃうんですね
蓄えると言ったって 理性に基づいてやってほしいんですね
計画的に借金するんじゃなくて
計画的に蓄えるんです
コマーシャルはね 計画的に借金しなさいでしょうに
そんなのありえない 初めからもう計画は崩れているんです
借金した時点で 計画的に蓄える
それも理性があってほしい
時々我々は一応貯金するだけで全然使わないとかね
時もあるでしょうに それでそのまま置いておいて死んじゃうんですね
だから 例えば若者がね
来年の夏は外国旅行したいという計画があったら
その計画的にそれから遊ぶことをやめて
ちょこちょこちょこちょこ蓄えればいいでしょうに
で 夏来ると もうちゃんと予約して
もう旅に出て 楽しく旅終わって帰っちゃうんですね
だから蓄えたものを適宜に使わなくちゃいけないんですね
使う道が全くないんだったら
全部もうばらまくと ない人々に
だからない人々 収入を得られる能力ない人々をね
怠け者にあげなさいと言ってないんです
だらしなくて怠けで ではなくて
もうやっぱり仕事はできない
人が何かあげなければもう生計は立てないという人々はいくらでもいますね
それはもうばらまいてくださいと
この貧しい人にあげる場合で
条件があるんですね 貧しいんだけど
自分で仕事したいんですね
例えば 農業はやりたくてたまらんんだけど
お金がなくてもう土地ちょこっとでも買えない
土地じゃないと手のひらで農業できるわけないでしょ
その人は農業で食べていきたいんですね
それだったら土地ちょっとぐらいあげなさいよと
それはその人が惨めになるわけじゃなくて
相手も喜んじゃうんですね
私はキャベツ作りたくていたんだけど
やっぱりいい土地がもらってなんてありがたいこと
必死でキャベツ作るんですよ
キャベツ作って これをそこいいキャベツでバンバン売れるし
それでその人は幸せになる
だからもらった人は惨めになったわけじゃないんです
だから 配るっていうことはそんな感じで
自分が使わない 使う道がないんだったら
むちゃくちゃ配れと というのは
仏教的な俗世間の道徳の範囲はそういうことなんですよ
ですから 蓄えてはいけませんということじゃないんです
蓄えなさいということなんです
俗世間的には どこかで旅行行く場合はね
新幹線のチケットだけ持って行く
だってそれで行けますからね
おかしいでしょうに いくらまだもうちょこっと乗っていかないと
そういうことで そこら辺ごちゃにしないでください
仏教はちゃんと俗世間に合わせて説法すると
セクションちゃんとあります
出世間の境地 悟りの境地を説明する説法も必ずあります
量的には出世間の方がはるかに量が多い
俗世間にはちょこちょこって言っただけで十分だ
あまりシンプルだからね
経典一つぶ出すでもう完璧に全部
あの 何て言えばかばせてやります
だから 喋るたびにお釈迦様を蓄えなさいと
そんな言うわけないでしょうに
それはもう在家の方々がそういう問題を持ってくると
まあそれだけのことは言います
そんなことなんですけど
蓄える場合は理性が必要なんですね
ただ貯金ということでは意味がないんですね
で 目的あって理性に基づいて蓄える時は
それ自体も俗世間的な楽しみがあるんです
例えば 子供が生まれたら
じゃあこの子の大学費まで
もう今お金 1円もないんだと
もうどうしようかと 貯金ゼロやと
子供が生まれたんだと
やっぱり子供はなんとか大学に行くまでなんとかお金を蓄えなくちゃということで
もう頑張ろうと 頑張れるでしょ
その場合はもうはい 今日は 1万円できそう
できたぞとか楽しいんですね
それで大学の入試になってくる
なんたこと 何の躊躇もなく胸を張って授業料を納めて
胸を張って帰ってくるんですね
だからそういう蓄えなんですよ
理性的に だからインドは物ないではなくて
インドは物ありすぎ 物ないのは日本なんです
あの連中 頭がおかしいだけ
金は取るは取るは取るは使わないだけ
とにかく取る 取っても服はだらし無いは
顔を洗わないは お風呂に入らないは
ろくなものを食わぬ だったらなんでお前にお金やと聞きたいんだけど
そこで我々はこのインド政府はね
馬鹿に無視されていて
破壊に追い込まれている仏教聖地もあるんだからね
インドは見てないでしょうに
高級ホテルも入ったでしょうに
外国人がいないでしょ
みんなインド人でしょ
インド人であれぐらいホテル経営できるんだから
赤字もなく あの連中どれほど金あると思いますかね
スリランカでもね ホテルあるんですけど
ほとんど外国人が入ってほしいという目的でやってるでしょうに
だから外国人来ないとものすごく大変なことになっちゃうんです
だって現地の人々にホテルを泊まることできないんでしょうに
あまりにも高くて それにインドに行ってみたら
まあすっごいもう最高級のホテルもあるしね
ニューデリーとかデリーはいいとホテルは泊まれませんでしたけど
今回はね 我々前行った時
何ホテル？タージでしたっけ？最後に
最後にタージとかホテル泊まりましたけど
ダライ・ラマ見たんだからね
で むちゃくちゃな高いホテルでしょうに
では中にいる泊まっている連中誰かというと
みんなインド人なんですね
たまたま外国人一人二人見えるんですけど
それもああいうホテルでお金払えるぐらい財力ある人々だけで
だから金がありすぎなんです
同時に頭が悪い 理性はゼロ
だって牛を拝んだり猿を拝んだりする連中でしょうね
日本人はね  そんなものあるわけじゃなくて
みんなそれぞれ頑張って均等にもうなんとかなんとかまあ頑張って生きてるんですからね
だからなんとか頑張って生きることは
あのインドと比較するとすごく豊かだなと感じるでしょ
それがポイントなんです
金持ちになるよりは まあなんとか間に合って生きる方が一番豊かなんです
だからインド人には金がありますよ
あるんだけど 貧乏なんです
人生を楽しむことを知らないんです
そこはまあ関係ない話で
一応蓄えっていうことは
一応俗世間では借金してはいけないです
お金ローンしてはいけないんですね
これはもう自分が計画性はない
理性がない 感情に負けたということなんです
だから 感情に負けないで理性に生きるということは
まあ自分に入る収入はしっかりと管理して使っているんだということで
ただ蓄えるだけのことは
仏教はすごく非難するんですね
理性が入らなきゃダメなんです
そこで中道っていうのが成り立つんです
蓄えるんだけど 理性があって蓄えますと
目的があって蓄えますと
その目的は将来のことを知らないんだからね
その目的はなかなか出てこなかったら
金はそのままでしょ それだったらもう配れと
もう必要でなくなったと
家で弁当を持ってどこかにハイキングに行くと
で 弁当食べようと 行ってハイキング行ったところで
すごい面白いレストランがあるんですね
まあびっくりと 思わなかったんですね
これ珍しい ここら辺でなんかすごい珍しい食べ物を作ってくれるところで
じゃあ食べてみようと
行ってそこで食べると
それって蓄えあったでしょ
あれどうする？目的はもうもうもう終わりでしょ
昼食べたんだから それを誰かにあげなさいでしょうに
すごいシンプルでしょ
自分が弁当ってものを蓄えて
今日の一日ということでやっちゃったんだけど
蓄えた目的が別な方法でも満たしてしまっちゃったんです
これまた背負って家に戻ってきて
冷蔵庫に入れてとかね
何がこれと 誰かにあげちゃえばいいでしょうに
そうするとそこは無駄になってないでしょ
自然破壊になってないでしょ